gab es mal ganz schlimmen tag wo ihr
gedacht habt um gottes willen wie soll
ich diesen tag überhaupt überstehen
ich glaube für mich die herausfordernde
zeit war als sich kouchner positiv war
und dann mit symptomen hier krank lag
das hat irgendwie einfach rechnet diese
grippe und du willst am liebsten den
ganzen tag geschlafen
das geht aber nicht also meine eltern
waren ja auch beide erkrankt lang auch
mit symptomen und kann jemanden zu gehen
kommt kann dir niemand helfen also dass
ich hier einfach an und lag schlitzen
auch der spiel machte im kinderzimmer
mit zwei kindern die um mich herum
liegen und da da muss ich schon sagen an
diese grenze bin ich so noch nie
gekommen als mutter das war schon das
war
[Musik]